Oh
well the first the first observation was
that there was a very strong correlation
between the extent to which the genome
in a cancer cell has changed and the
lethality of the cancer so that if one's
looking at a cancer and there are lots
of changes in the genome that patient is
less likely to survive than a patient
whose genome has just begun to evolve
that was the first major uh observation
there are a lot of particular details
that emerged from those studies that is
we found the locations of jeans they're
called oncogenes and tumor suppressor
genes the individual genes at these
places many of the changes are what we
call recurrent they happen over and over
again and different people with the same
cancer and there are genes in those
regions that one thing show functionally
alter the capacity of the cancer cell to
grow divided or spread in the individual
so this has been an engine also for the
discovery of new cancer genes we weren't
the first ones to do this people have
been using these techniques for a while
including ourselves or periods of ten
years or more sometimes the particular
drugs that are given to a patient are
determined by whether that patient has a
particular gene amplification in their
cancer the most well-known example of
that is patients with amplifications of
the her2 gene will likely respond to
Herceptin so our view has been that
specific amplifications will correlate
with drug sensitivity we're in the
middle of exploring that and we've also
begun to look at single cells within
cancer so we can now actually look at
the genome of an individual cell within
the cancer and that's giving us a much
more detailed picture of how the cancer
has evolved so we think we'll be able to
identify for example the earliest cells
the earliest mutations in a cancer
that'll tell us how the cancer began to
grow in the first place it'll also tell
us what you might call sort of the
tribal or population structure of the
cancer and that tells us about how the
cancer is how the individual cancer
cells are interacting with each other
interacting with a host and migrating
throughout the cancer and possibly
migrating throughout the patient so that
we think that by looking at the
individual cells of a cancer we'll be
able to improve clinical staging and
drug treatment enormously but this is a
long-term project this will take us five
years ten years
alright well I can give you two ways
there many ways that this research could
impact the clinic i can give you two
very concrete examples if a new drug is
being tested in a population with a
particular type of cancer one might look
for correlations between response to the
drug and the genome profile that could
tell you which which patients are likely
to respond to a drug so that patients
don't have to take a drug that's not
going to benefit them and don't have to
suffer the side effects of a drug that's
not going to benefit them and that will
ultimately lead to the design of better
drugs a second way in this next way is
you know it's not not not quite science
fiction but we're looking a little bit
into the future when we can examine the
genome of individual cells and can do
that cheaply we can develop tests early
detection tests or cancer that are based
on blood so it's now being appreciated
widely that even cancers that perhaps
have not yet metastasize release their
cells into the bloodstream and do so in
fairly large numbers so that you can
collect cells from the blood
unidentified them as a kind of cell that
shouldn't be in the blood but people
haven't yet been able to look at the
genomes of these individual cells so
some of the methodology that we're
developing will enable us to do that so
you can imagine that at some time in the
future you can draw blood in the
doctor's office and just like the
doctors now do what's called a blood
count to determine how many white blood
cells you have whether it's likely that
you've got a fever they'll be able to be
able to sort out from the blood the
small proportion of cells that might be
being spun off by a cancer somewhere
undetected in the body and by looking at
the genome of those cells and possibly
by also looking at the RNA that those
cells are making I'll be able to say
this person has a malignant bone cancer
and then then you can look for that so
this technology ultimately can lead to
early detection for